[Applaus]
[Musik]
im november 2020 fand die umstrittenste
war in der geschichte der usa statt der
anstieg der wahlbeteiligung die
briefwahl der plötzliche umschwung
zugunsten der demokraten und die
anschuldigungen aller art welche dann
davon mündeten dass eine aufgebrachte
menge ins kapitol vorrang und einige von
ihnen sogar ums leben kam
diese erfahrung war plötzlich eine menge
fragen darüber auf wie genau die
amerikanische demokratie funktioniert
denn es gibt in den usa viele methoden
mit den wahlen so migriert werden können
dass es nicht die mehrheit der wähler es
die über das wahlergebnis entscheidet
sondern jemand anderes und eine der
frappierenden methoden zur manipulation
ist das so genannte carry ein
politisches instrument welches außerhalb
der usa ziemlich unbekannt ist das aber
sagt yasin die wohl mächtigste
maschinerie zur verzerrung von
wahlergebnissen darstellt dabei wurde
der im entering nicht von beiden clinton
oder obama erfunden oder irgendeines
superschurken wir sprechen über eine
mehr als zwei jahrhunderte als praxis
auf die sowohl vertreter der
demokratischen partei als auch der
republikanischen partei zurückgreifen
die frage ist also was ist gary man
direkt baum ist es nicht schon längst
egal
und was noch wichtiger ist zu was könnte
die managerin in den kommenden jahren
führen
heute werden wir hier auf visual politik
all diese fragen beantworten und zwar
die immer mit einem blick auf ein wenig
geschichte
gehrys salamander das s bahn system ist
komplex und es gibt aber nicht unbedingt
darum wer die meisten stimmen bekommt
denkt zum beispiel daran was 2016
geschah ist trump die wahl gewonnen
obwohl er drei millionen stimmen weniger
hatte als hillary clinton etwas das
übrigens schon fünf mal passiert ist und
immer der republikanischen partei zugute
kam
dennoch ist dies nicht auf
wahlmanipulation zurückzuführen denn die
vereinigten staaten sind eine situation
aus 50 bundesstaaten die seit 1787 nach
und nach gegründet wurden heute ist die
föderale form absolut konsolidiert aber
im laufe der jahre kam die differenzen
zwischen den verschiedenen bundesstaaten
immer wieder zum vorschein und sie
eskalierten manchmal zu schaffen
konflikten mit dem amerikanischen
bürgerkrieg in der mitte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts als höhepunkt deshalb wurde
von anfang an einen wal mechanismus
eingeführt da eine ganz bestimmte
aufgabe erfüllen sollte den sieht eines
kandidaten zu verhindern
der nur von einer region des landes
unterstützt wurde selbst wenn diese
unterstützung sehr sehr stark war
deshalb wählt man in den usa den
präsidenten nicht direkt sondern über
das elektro college das gremium der
wahlmänner
wer in einem staat die meisten stimmen
bekommt bekommt alle stimmen dieses
staates im elektronik college dabei
spielt es keine rolle wie groß der
vorsprung des gewinnes ist egal ob man
den staat mit einem oder 25 prozent
vorsprung gewinnt die anzahl der
delegierten die man bekommt ist die
gleich die überschüssigen prozente des
siegers verfallen so zu sagen nun wir
wissen das alles eigentlich unser wissen
auch wieso die zahl der wählerstimmen
auf bundesebene nicht entscheidend davon
ist der präsident wird das werden wir ja
wieder bei einer direktwahl die tatsache
dass ist keine landesweite
proportionalität bei den
präsidentschaftswahlen gibt stellt
jedoch keine bahnen deflation dar
im gegensatz ist kleinere schwächere
staaten davor in der bedeutungslosigkeit
zu verschwinden weil sie von den großen
und starken jedesmal überstimmt werden
also hier haben wir es nicht mit gary
mentoren zu tun
gary gray kommt nämlich bei
parlamentswahlen zum einsatz
sowohl bei wahlen der parlamente in den
bundesstaaten als auch deshalb als
debatten hause ist auf bundesebene
warum
[Musik]
bei präsidentschaftswahlen bildet jeder
bundesstaat quasi einen einzelnen großen
wahlkreis bei den parlamentswahlen
jedoch wird das territorium des jedem
bundesstaat so aufgeteilt damit pro
wahlkreis je ein abgeordneter ins
parlament gewählt wird
und da über die genaue einteilung der
wahlbezirke auch politiker entscheidet
geschehen plötzlich ganz wundersame
dinge
die republikaner gewannen bei den
kongresswahlen 50,3 prozent der stimmen
in north carolina
sie bekamen szenen von 13 sitzen zehn
von dreizehn entsprechen aber 77 prozent
der sitze die north carolina im
repräsentantenhaus hatte die demokraten
haben also mit 46 prozent der stimmen
nur 23 prozent der sitze erhalten
komisch nicht wahr
die anliegen zuschauer dieses wunder
wurde wirklichkeit mithilfe vorne genau
berryman gering denn die grenzen der
wahlkreise werden nicht durch
geografische oder historische regionen
vorgegeben sie werden regelmäßig
angepasst und neu zugeschnitten alle
zehn jahre werden sie sowohl für die
parlamente der bundesstaaten als auch
für das us repräsentantenhaus in so
viele bezirke aufgeteilt wie sitze zu
vergeben sind und die einzige bedingung
dabei ist dass alle wahlkreise mehr oder
weniger die gleiche anzahl von
einwohnern haben
ansonsten könnte sich ja die jeweils an
der macht befindliche partei die
wahlkreise so zurechtschneiden dass ihre
kandidatin bevorteilt werden
es ist also extrem wichtig wie genau die
wahlkreis kleinsten gezogen werden denn
grundsätzlich hat man dazu erst zwei
möglichkeiten zum beispiel so wie es im
bundesstaat iowa üblich ist mit hilfe
eines computerprogramms dass die
wahlkreise so optimal auf teilt das sich
daraus keine politischen verzerrung und
ergin vorsätzlich nicht wahr
aber das ist leider nicht die normen die
meisten bundesstaaten haben die
unrühmliche tradition das einfach jene
partei welche im jeweiligen parlament
gerade die mehrheit stellt wahlkreise
nach ihrem gusto festlegt und wenn sie
dabei auf gary mentoring zurückgreift
neben die karten mit den wahlkreisen
sehr sehr skurrile formen an
wie skurril nun schaut euch hier mal den
distrikt in illinois an gut mittlerweile
fragen sich viele von euch
wahrscheinlich warum diese unredliche
praxis ist so eine komische bezeichnung
hat geri murray wäre ein simpler und
aussagekräftiger begriff die wahlkreis
verzerrung nicht besser nun damit ihr
versteht warum die wahlkreis verzerrung
in den usa gary managerin genannt wird
müssen wir bis ins jahr 1800
12 zurückgeben damals erließ der
gouverneur von massachusetts durch gary
eine massnahme welche die wahlkreises so
zu recht schnell dass er seiner partei
der von thomson gegründeten demokratisch
republikanischen partei einen wal
vorteil verschaffen konnte ein neuer
wahlkreis hatte dabei eine derart
konische form dass eine zeitung die
boston gesellt eine karikatur daraus
macht der neue wahlkreis erinnerte alle
an einem genau an ein salamander und so
wurde die wortschöpfung gary männer
geboren eine kombination aus gary und
sollte interessant nicht was jedoch
viele von euch mehr interessieren wird
als diese kleine anekdote ist die
brennende frage denn während der mehr
als 200 jahre die seitdem vergangen sind
niemand versucht dieses spiel irgendwie
zu schaffen und die antwort lautet ja
und das schon sehr oft einer davon ist
will ihren weg fort ein rechtsprofessor
an der universität von wisconsin
er trat dort das game engine an das von
der republikanischen partei in diesem
bundesstaat passiert wird dessen
ergebnis war nämlich dass die demokraten
mit 53 prozent der stimmen nur 38
prozent der sitze im kongress zu kommen
allerdings gibt es bei gering
keine gute und böse partei wenn die
demokraten machen sobald sie nur die
gelegenheit dazu haben ebenso gerne von
gary menschen gebraucht die republikaner
erinnerungen zum beispiel ein waffen sie
total verrückt aussehende wahlkreis
karten um 78 wahlkreisen für das
repräsentantenhaus zu ergattern
deswegen zog professor wippert bis zum
obersten gerichtshof machte sehr genau
klar wo es bei männern geht in einer
demokratie sollen die bürger ihre
gesetzgeber wählen invest konsum haben
jedoch die gesetzgeber ihre wähler
gewählt durch die neueinteilung der
bezirke die es praktisch unmöglich für
demokraten macht eine mehrheit in der
state assembly zu erobern egal wie viele
stimmen sie landesweit für demokratische
kandidaten bekommen wenn wir mit folter
rechtsprofessor der universität auf ein
bisschen sind ja und wollt ihr wissen
was die gerichte diese eigentlich
glasklare angelegenheit entschieden
haben dann haltet euch jetzt mal gut
fest
[Musik]
germering klage abgewiesen
mit gary musste sich der oberste
gerichtshof der usa schon sehr
aufgeschlossen und die antwort des
höchsten bundesgerichts lautet durch
jedes mal
der winter ist nicht die feine englische
art befindet sich aber leider außerhalb
der entscheidungskompetenz der gericht
nun eigentlich ist das nicht die ganze
wahrheit im jahr 2004 wäre es fast zu
einem bahnbrechenden urteil bekommt als
die neun richter des obersten
gerichtshofs über die möglichkeit den
grenzen zu setzen gespalten waren aber
am ende gab es dann doch nur business as
usual
jeder richter am ende ausschlaggebend
war argumentierte dass das problem darin
bestünde dass eine formel für die
aufteilung von beschränkungen für
germering die keinen erheblichen
eingriff in das politische leben der
nation bedeuten würde noch nicht
gefunden werden konnte
zehn jahre später im jahr 2018 stammt
germering erneut vor dem obersten
gerichtshof und es ging wieder als
sieger hervor
supreme court lehnt es ab grenzen für
politisches gering zu setzen der oberste
gerichtshof wer sich zum thema green
rendering offensichtlich aus der politik
heraushalten aber eine ausnahme hat er
doch definiert diskriminierung von
wählern aus rassistischen gründen anders
ausgedrückt heißt das aber dass der pott
hat parteipolitischen rendering
vollkommen grünes licht gegeben
nachdem von gerichten also kein appell
für mehr zu erwarten ist besteht die
einzige hoffnung in bürgerinitiativen
bürgerinitiativen wie zb waters north
politischen das ist eine gruppe von
aktivisten aus michigan die es
tatsächlich geschafft hat in ihrem
bundesstaat ein referendum über gary
mengering durchzuboxen
und das ergebnis sieht auf voller linie
für die weder niederlage für die
kritiker die gestaltung der wahlbezirke
michigan wird nun in die hände einer
kommission gelegt welches zu gleichen
teilen aus vertreter der beiden großen
parteien und ausgewählten bürgern
besteht ähnliche kommission gibt es in
arizona und kalifornien schon seit
jahrzehnten und 1 colorado utah und
mystery sind ähnlich initiativen wie
fotos und politisches am start das alles
ist schön und gut aber es gibt zwei
probleme erstens funktionieren diese
bürgerbegehren nicht überall weil sie
etwa zehn anderen bundesstaaten
überhaupt in betracht gezogen werden
können und zweitens können sie auch ganz
gewaltig nach hinten los gehen menschen
ist nun mal sehr oft widersprüchliche
dinge tun wie zb im erwähnten missouri
die wähler haben den plan für eine
saubere neuverteilung der wahlkreise in
misery denen sie 2018 eingeführt haben
wieder aufgehoben
es scheint also kein allheilmittel gegen
die gm manager zugeben müssen sich annis
also immer damit leben und was würde ich
dazu sagen wenn ich euch verraten dass
die demokratische partei gerade durch
gary minderung bei den nächsten wahlen
ihre mehrheit im capitol verlieren
könnte auch wenn sie mehr wählerstimmen
gewinnen würde
aufgepasst die volkszählung
alle zehn jahre wird in den vereinigten
staaten eine volkszählung durchgeführt
und auf grundlage ihrer ergebnis eine
neueinteilung der wahlkreise
durchgeführt damit den
bevölkerungszuwachs bzw abnahme in den
einzelnen bundesstaaten rechnung
getragen werden kann
schließlich will jeder staat dass er
eine gerechte und proportionale zahl von
sitzen im parlament mit seinen
abgeordneten besetzen kann
die letzte solche volkszählung liegt im
jahr 2020 ab und was falsch 2020 noch
stadt ja genau
aber auch noch etwas anderes kommt ja
darauf genau
es wurde ein neuer präsident gewählt und
genau dies war im hinblick auf die neue
einteilung der wahlkreise sehr wichtig
denn als eine seiner letzten maßnahmen
im amt eurozone donald trump an illegale
maßnahmen von der volkszählung
auszuschließen und joe biden annulierte
diese anordnung daran sofort am ersten
tag nach seiner amtseinführung nur
größer weise hat er damit seine eigene
partei den demokraten in den fuß
geschossen
durch die aufhebung von tanz anordnung
zur erzählung illegale einwanderer
arbeiten den republikanern in texas ein
oder zwei zusätzliche mandate im
repräsentantenhaus
in der tat wird tags ist voraussichtlich
jener stars sein der am meisten von der
90 aufteilung profitieren wird unter
trucks anordnung würde text hast nur 91
cent bekommen bei berücksichtigung
illegale einwanderer nun aber bis zu 2
und florida einen weiteren gesprächen
jetzt und zwei staaten die seit mehr als
20 jahren hochburgen republikaner sind
auf der anderen seite verlieren dadurch
hochburgen der demokratischen partei wie
in new york und kalifornien sitze
denn insgesamt wird die zahl der
volksvertreterin reppenhorst konstant
bei 430 gehalten und dann ist bei den
letzten wahlen zum repräsentantenhaus
die demokraten gerade einmal einen
vorsprung von neun abgeordneten lassen
alles deutet also darauf hin dass die
republikaner bei den zwischenwahlen 2022
möglicherweise die mehrheit im
repräsentantenhaus übernehmen werden
einfach aufgrund der neuen aufteilung
ohne auch nur eine wählerstimme hier zu
gewinnen zu müssen
genau an diesem punkt kommt ja wieder
unser schönes carey mengering ins spiel
und das läuft dann so ab da der
bevölkerungszuwachs in texas und florida
vor allem den rändern großer städte zu
gute kommt und der städtische wähler nun
mal überwiegend demokraten wählt müssen
die republikaner einfach nur ländliche
gebiete mit stadtnahen gebieten so
kombinieren dass die wählerstimmen der
städter in jedem wahlkreis in der
minderheit sind und damit quasi
verfallen in der tat wird an den
wahlkreis karten von houston engländer
und ohio bereits fleißig herum
geschnitten um den einen kandidaten
vorteile zu verschaffen
allerdings sind die republikaner nicht
ganz alleine die demokraten bereiten
sich ebenfalls darauf vor das gleiche in
von ihnen kontrollierten wurde stadt zu
tun
in new york zum beispiel demokratische
abgeordnete schicken sich an die
kleinsten ihre eigenen wahlkreise neu zu
ziehen um sich über jahre hinweg dem
mehrheit zu sichern aber kürzlich hat
die demokratische partei im
repräsentantenhaus die sogenannte
titusville verabschiedet eine
weitreichende gesetzentwurf der den
gehry managerin ein für alle mal ein
ende bereiten würde
und natürlich wird am ende wieder nichts
passieren das ist politik bis 60 prozent
mehrheit im senat und er umfasst zu
viele punkte die den republikanischen
senatoren ein dorn im auge sind man muss
sich aber auch über einen anderen sehr
negativen effekt des geringen bewusst
sein denn viele wissen nicht dass ist
gerade gering ist dass die politik
insgesamt und die gesellschaft
maßgeblich verändert es treibt nämlich
die polarisierung des politischen
diskurses und des politischen handelns
entscheidend voran
lasst mich das mal kurz erklären mit
gary winick wird einer partei praktisch
statt durchmarsch in einem wahlkreis
garantiert es ist also klar aus welcher
partei
der sieger kommt somit verschiebt sich
der eigentliche wahlkampf jedoch in die
vorwahlen in denen die einzelnen
kandidaten der sieger datei um ihre
nominierung im wahlkreis streiten und in
diesem vor wahlen gewinnen oft jene
kandidaten die mit den radikalsten
versprechen die aufmerksam
ihre parteibasis auf sich ziehen können
sie müssen ja nicht mit kompromissen
oder moderaten positionen werben um
wechselwähler der gegnerischen partei
für sich zu gewinnen das ist also der
stand der dinge
was meint ihr denkt ihr landsmann gary
mentoring respektieren sollte weil es
einfach zu den spielregeln gehört die
nun mal von beiden parteien genutzt
werden oder denkt die es wieder besser
ihm ein für alle mal einhalt zu gebieten
und wie sieht es in eurem land aus habt
ihr auch schon etwas von wahlkreis
manipulationen mitbekommen halt auch
bitte eure meinungen und erfahrungen in
einem kurzen kommentar mit uns und auch
einen anderen zuschauern ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat was ja
geht uns bitte ein kleines lied teilt es
mit euren freunden und vergesst nicht
unseren kanal auch zu abonnieren macht
gut und ist
[Musik]